commençons par le design tout arrive
dans cette boîte ici qui semble être une
boîte plutôt recyclée ici à noter qu'il
y a aucun bloc de charge inclus grosse
force de ce produit arrive dans
énormément de couleurs on va avoir le
vert d'eau le graphite un espèce de gris
un peu clair le violet aussi qui est pas
mal le crème et après vous avez deux
couleur exclusive uniquement au site
samsung.com à savoir ce petit bleu qui
est tout mignon et le orange d'ailleurs
si un de ces produits vous intéressent
je vous mets bien évidemment un lien
juste en bas dans la description vous
l'aurez vu ici on retrouve un design qui
est très proche du Galaxy S23 on reprend
exactement les mêmes codes à savoir vos
trois optiques photos qui vont venir
ressortir directement pour le coup le
cadre ressort aussi énormément à noter
qu'ici vous avez un cadre en aluminium
qui vient pour la résistance Samsung
nous annonce que c'est de l'aluminium
recyclé on trouve peu ou prou le même
design du Samsung Galaxy S23 are truc
qui est pas mal au niveau de ce design
c'est que les bords sont quand même
assez fins cont les votre caméra qui est
là bon alors fin on a connu plus fin sur
des smartphones avec les écrans incurvés
si c'est pas le cas c'est un écran plat
mais globalement le taf est fait on se
parle une dalle de 6,4 pouces dynamic
amolet 2x donc exactement la même techno
qu'on retrouve dans les Galaxy S23 on
est dans le haut du panier hein si donc
c'est normale une dalle 120 Hz
adaptative et surtout ici un pic de
luminosité que Samsung nous annonce
aller jusqu'à
1450 n on est en extérieur alors le
temps est pas juste Dingo Dingo mais on
voit bien alors on a peut pas tester
forcément on est ici en plein mois de
décembre avec un gros soleil dessus mais
comme c'est là déjà globalement on voit
que c'est bien et que cet écran est
vraiment extrêmement bien lé audio on
retrouve des haut parleurs stéréo vous
en avez un ici sur le côté et un autre
qui est juste là bon un grand classique
ça marche bien une fois de plus à la
différence du S23 côté performance on va
pas retrouver un processeur de Qualcom
ce n'est pas un Snapdragon 8 gen 2 non
c'est un exyos 2200 qui lui aussi est
gravé en 4 nanomè bien évidemment c'est
un pros 5G sauf qu'ici on ira moins loin
que ce qu'on peut venir retrouver avec
le Galaxy S23 on a également une grosse
batterie de 4500 mahh de la recharge
rapide 25 W qui vous le rechargera à 50
% en seulement 30 minutes il est
également compatible charge sans fil et
charge inversée pour venir recharger vos
écouteurs ça c'est plutôt pratique côté
photo vous avez trois optiques un
capteur principal de 50 mégapixels
stabilisé qui ouvre F 1.8 un ultra grand
angle de 12 mégapixels et un
téléobjectif de 8 mégapixels
téléobjectif x 3 sans oublier une caméra
de selfie de 10 mégapixel comme
d'habitude chez Samsung vous avez plein
de modes photos portrait vidéo plus pro
nuit nourriture panorama super ralenti
le mode portrait la vue des réalisateurs
et le single take et ce qui est
intéressant c'est toute cette
flexibilité qu'on va venir retrouver au
travers de ce smartphone c'est un
smartphone qui ctifié IP68 résistant à
l'eau et à la poussière il a du wifi 6e
donc il reste très actuel et c'est un
smartphone qui est disponible à partir
du 8 décembre dans deux configurations
différent 8 Go de RAM 128 Go de stockage
à 699 € et un8 256 à 759 €. la question
est à qui se destine ce Galaxy S23 F feu
et qu'est-ce qu'on va venir en faire
c'est indiqué dans le nom on se parle
ici de la gamme S la gamme S c'est quoi
c'est la gamme Performance et la gamme
photo vidéo chez Samsung c'est donc le
très haut de gamme sauf que dans la
gamme S vous avez le Galaxy S23 le S23
plus et le S23 ultra vient d'arriver ce
S23 e qui se situe juste en dessous du
Galaxy S23 on n'est pas sur un modèle
light il sont pas venus renier ici sur
les performances quoi que on en parle un
peu plus tard on va donc retrouver tout
ce qu'on qu'on attend dans smartphone
Galaxy S à savoir une super dalle
dynamic AMOLED 2x qui marche vraiment
bien extrêmement bien calibré c'est la
même dalle que le S23 S23 plus S23 ultra
donc ici aucune mauvaise surprise grand
écran 6,4 pou donc pour tout ce qui va
être contenu multimédia film séries
gaming il y a aucun problème le fait
d'avoir un taux de rafrachissement qui
monte jusqu'à 120 Hz vous permettra
également en terme de gaming de gagner
en fluidité notamment lorsque vous
allezenir vous amuser à vous balader
dans vos paramètres c'est fluide ça
réagit très très bien et ça c'est cool
l'autre point fort c'est bien évidemment
tout ce qui va être photos et vidéo avec
ces trois capteurs trois voir quatre
capteurs avec le capteur que vous avez à
l'avant çappte quoi ça apporte de la
modularité là où sur un smartphone
milieu de gamme on aura un grand angle
et un ultra grand angle pas de
téléobjectif comme on est sur la gamme S
de Samsung on vient avoir un
téléobjectif donc on peut venir zoomer x
3 optiquement directement ça c'est quand
même cool vous pouvez également payer
avec Samsung pay Google pay il a toutes
les dernières techno le wifi 6e il est
résistant à l'eau et à la poussière IP68
bref c'est un smartphone hyper actuel
tout ce qu'on attend un smartphone dans
le haut de gamme on retrouve ici sur le
Galaxy S23 F pour venir filmer comme ça
on filme en 4K on peut monter jusqu'en
8k ici pour venir filmer vu qu'on a
quand même une grosse capacité de calcul
je peux venir filmer jusqu'en 8k 24
images par seconde donc une fois de plus
ce qu'on veut voir ici c'est de la
flexibilité on peut également venir
filmer sur l'ultra grand angle là voyez
je suis sur le X 06 alors je peux venir
changer dynamiquement je passe sur le X
1 je passe sur le X 3 je peux venir
zoomer directement le maître mot de ce
smartphone c'est la polyvalence pour
venir filmer avec vous voyez c'est quand
même extrêmement pratique il y a aussi
le mode vidéo portrait je pe venir
changer ensuite voyez hop mon fond en
glitch je peux passer en point de
couleur je peux passer en grand cercle
des gros points forts ici aussi c'est la
vue du réalisateur voyez je me vois je
suis juste là et je peux venir filmer de
l'autre côté je peux venir changer
d'ailleurs ça c'est assez marrant hop je
passe ici sur mon zoom optique x 3 mon
téléobjectif je peux passer ensuite sur
mon ultra grand angle il y a du vent
j'espère que le son va aller et je me
mets comme ça donc une fois de plus on
retrouve tout ce qui fait le succès de
la gamme S Samsung chez Samsung et hop
là regardez je switch comme ça
directement une fois de plus c'est malin
c'est pratique et ça marche bien côté
photo de nuit c'est quand même supr
efficace alors là je vais vous montrer
regardez là c'est une photo de nuit
prise en mode un peu classique et là on
passe sur une photo de nuit prise en
mode nuit ce qui est intéressant c'est
que ça réos quand même vachement les
couleurs et les lumières on va venir
exposer un peu plus longtemps la façade
les lumières là le fond également c'est
quand même vachement mieux venir zoomer
un petit peu la nuit mais on va pas trop
loin parce qu'après on vient quand même
dégrader un peu la qualité mais ça reste
efficace le sapin de Noël prise d'une
façon un peu classique et là en mode
nuit une fois de plus seré Aué c'est
beaucoup plus joli et c'est beaucoup
plus efficace photo classique mode nuit
vous voyez ça rien à voir là c'est le
mode nourriture je trouve ça aussi assez
efficace là c'est un mode photo
classique mode nourriture ça vient
soutenir ça vient saturer davantage un
poil troflateteur mais ça marche pareil
mode nourriture classique sur un
couscous et paf la photo classique
également de couscous et là paf ça
sature d'avantage avec le mode
nourriture je vous montre quelques
petites photos par-ci par là la météo
est pas folle folle en ce moment mais ça
fonctionne grand angle ultra grand angle
rien à dire la colorimétrie est très
très proche voyez entre le grand angle
et l'ultra grand angle pour voir qu'on
est pas sur les même capteur ça
fonctionne là sur le zoom x 3 optique
c'est bien c'est détaillé c'est net ça
fonctionne bien on passe en x 10 x 20 x
30 bon on va éviter d'aller trop loin
mais globalement le taf est fait pareil
là regardez la couleur c'est intéressant
cette colorimétrie vu qu'on a une
différence de capteur c'est très très
proche ça marche bien là on est au x 3
là on va au x 10 x 20 x 30 là pareil de
la même manière moi ce que j'aime bien
c'est cette correspondance des couleurs
qui est V même très très très très bonne
ici on évite et on le voit on vient pas
trop zoomer parce qu'à un moment on perd
quand même en qualité
mais globalement c'est la polyvalence
qui est là qui est le maître mot au
niveau de ce smartphone et qui donne un
rendu qui est extrêmement appréciable au
niveau des photos comment est-ce que se
positionne ce Galaxy S23 et feu dans la
gamme comment est-ce qu'il est par
rapport au Galaxy S23 première chose à
savoir chez Samsung vous avez quatre
produits dans la gamme S23 S23 F feu S23
S23 plus S23 ultra bien évidemment ce
produit est beaucoup plus proche du S23
que du S23 ultra qui est beaucoup plus
loin c'est pas tout à fait le même
produit même s'il est dans la même gamme
la vraie question c'est est-ce que ce
smartphone est un vrai bon plan ou pas
alors regardez on va regarder le tarif
c'est déjà un bon indicateur puisque
chez Samsung si vous regardez sur le S23
et bien vous avez deux configs 128 256
on commence à 799 € ça c'est un point
important sur un 128 ici on commence à
699 € ça veut dire qu'il y a 100 balles
d'écart entre ces deux smartphones
regardez a un tour de magie je vois que
mon galaxy S23 plus est à 1219 € et
lorsque je vais pour l'acheter
directement sur le site de Samsung t il
tombe à
899 € en version 8 256 donc en fait lui
aujourd'hui il est à 899 € et ou vous
êtes pas sans savoir que les Galaxy S24
vont arriver d'ici quelques mois a
priori début 2024 donc forcément on
commence un petit peu à diminuer les
tarifs ici quoi que et à titre d'info je
sais pas si vous le savez les tarifs
diminuent assez rapidement chez Samsung
qui fait que aujourd'hui un Galaxy S23
fe que vous trouvez à 699 qu'on trouve
un peu moins cher un peu plus tard mais
on en reparle un peu plus loin dans la
vidéo et après on vient regarder sur S23
ultra qui est ici à 1199 €. donc le truc
qui doit vachement nous intéresser ici
alors on oublie le S23 ultra qui est un
peu à part c'est que en fait on a un
palier de 100 ball entre le S23 F le S23
et le S23 plus qui en fait nous permet
de voir le travail que vient faire
Samsung ici c'est-à-dire tous les 100 €
dans le haut de gamme on a un smartphone
de la gamme Galaxy S23 alors on aurait
tendance à se dire mais qu'est-ce qui me
permet de faire le choix entre mon
galaxy S23 F et mon galaxy S23 parce qu'
quand même quelques petites différences
à venir connaître ici la première c'est
au niveau du verre sur le Galaxy S23
vous avez un corningoria glass victus de
2e génération donc ce qui aujourd'hui
potentiellement plus résistant tandis
que sur le S23 fe pour 100 balles de
moins vous avez deux générations voir
trois générations d'avant Corning Royal
glass 5 bon vous allez pas non plus
jeter votre téléphone partout en
permanence d'autant plus que c'est quand
même pas mal de venir protéger avec une
coque mais bon la différence qui nous
intéresse réellement ici c'est que sur
le S23 vous avez une dalle de 6,1 pou
tandis que sur le S23 F fe vous avez une
dalle un peu plus grosse de 6,4 pouces
et ça nous intéresse parce que regardez
sur le site de Samsung sur le S23 plus
et bien vous avez déjà une dalle de 6,4
pouces ça veut dire qu'en fait avec le
S23 fe vous allez retrouver la même
taille de dalle que vous avez sur un
Galaxy S23 3 plus autre différence et
pas des moindres sur le Galaxy S23 vous
avez un processeur de Qualcomm c'est le
Snapdragon 8 gen 2 qui est juste une
petite bombe tandis que sur le S23 F feu
on va retrouver ici un exyos 2200 qui
est aussi dans le haut du panier qui est
très bien mais qui sur les benchmark va
être un peu moins bon que le Snapdragon
8 gen 2 alors ceci étant dit entre nous
le temps que vous mettiez l'exyos 2200 à
genou il en faudra après il faut savoir
que un processeur ça ne joue pas que sur
la performance notamment en terme de
gaming de ça va jouer également sur
l'autonomie de votre smartphone et ici
l'exinos 2200 s'en sort quand même
plutôt pas mal la batterie c'est aussi
un sujet intéressant regardez sur le
Galaxy S23 fe vous avez une batterie de
4500 mAh tandis que sur le Galaxy S23 et
si vous venez regarder sur le site de
Samsung vous avez une batterie de 3900
mahh ce qui est quand même assez
convenable mais si vous regardez le
Galaxy S23 plus vous allez voir que vous
avez une batterie de 4700 mahh donc une
fois de plus ce Galaxy S23 fe est à la
croisée des chemins un peu mieux loti
que le S23 un peu moins bien LTI que le
S23 plus autre différence intéressante
c'est au niveau de la photo N a plus de
place sur cette feuille j'ai écrit trop
gros que ce soit grand angle ou l'ultra
grand angle ça sera la même chose la
différence va se faire au niveau du
téléobjectif puisque sur le S23 vous
avez un capteur de 10 mégapixel sur
votre téléobjectif ici vous avez un
capteur de 8 mgapixel bon c'est un peu
moins cher on en aura un peu moins on
s'en doutera il y a aussi une différence
avec la caméra de selfie qui va être de
12 mégapixel ici sur le S23 S23 plus et
uniquement de 10 mégapixel sur votre S23
fe alors ok je vous ai montré beaucoup
de choses mais qu'est-ce qu' fait
réellement la différence ici pour moi
qu'est-ce qui est vraiment intéressant
pour vous et qu'est-ce qui doit
permettre de vous faire un avis ici et
bien pour moi la seule vraie grosse
différence qui est intéressante va être
au niveau de l'écran parce que c'est là
où vous allez passer le plus de temps
bah oui un smartphone on passe plus de
temps à le regarder qu'à faire autre
chose ça me paraît quand même assez
logique qui doit vraiment guider votre
choix entre le S23 fe et le S23 bien
évidemment il y a le tarif c'est
important 100 balles voilà mais les
tarifs vont pas tarder à bouger on en
parle dans quelques instants ce qui pour
moi fait vraiment la différence c'est
cette taille d'écran 6,1 pou 6,4 pouces
vous me direz 0 0,3 pouces est-ce que ça
a son importance ça a suffisamment
d'importance pour venir orienter les
personnes qui se posaient la même
question entre le S23 et le S23 plus
cétait quasiment le même smartphone avec
le S23 i vous aurez un écran un peu plus
grand un écran un peu plus confort pour
venir regarder tous vos contenus
multimédia certes vous avez pas le
processeur de Qualcomm le Snapdragon 8
gen 2 vous avez un exenos 2200 mais vous
avez une batterie un peu plus grosse
donc en terme d'autonomie ça se vaut
aucun problème et une fois de plus soyez
rassuré avec l'exenos 2200 vous allez
pouvoir faire ce que vous voulez vous
allez pas me le coucher certes c'est pas
dragon 8 gen 2 mais je serais surpris je
serais vraiment surpris il faudra me le
marquer dans les commentaires à ce
moment-là que vous mettiez le smartphone
à genou on est donc ici sur un S23 un
peu moins spcké mais pas réellement on
ira un peu moins loin en terme de photo
un peu moins loin ceci est en deal t
l'objectif c'est parce qu'on va venir
utiliser le plus la caméra de selfie non
plus vous avez votre grand angle de 50
mégapixel qui reste inchangé votre ultra
grand angle de 12 mégapixel qui reste
également inchangé donc aujourd'hui pour
moi à 100 balles de moins le Galaxy S2 2
Fe reste quand même super intéressant on
retrouve donc ici avec le Galaxy S23 fe
tout le savoir-faire de Samsung dans un
smartphone haut de gamme sans concession
à quelques petites choses prês bien
évidemment vous l'avez vu alors
attention si vous êtes Maniac au
maniaque et que vous ne supportez pas
les traces de doigts sur un téléphone
vous risquez réellement de souffrir ici
parce que avec son dos et bien il prend
quand même vachement les traces de dot
Samsung a dû venir arbitrer des choix et
une fois de plus je trouve qu'ils ont
fait un choix qui est quand même plutôt
pas mal lorsque j'ai parlé avec eux
lorsqu'ils m'ont expliqué le produit je
leur ai dit mais attendez votre S23 F
feu et votre S23 ils sont beaucoup trop
proche pour que ça puisse marcher mais
le truc qui fait réellement la
différence c'est effectivement une fois
de plus cette taille d'écran qui va
Rener un peu plus de confort et je
trouve ça assez malin parce que si vous
avez proposé un Samsung Galaxy S23 F
avec une dalille de 6,1 pou comme le
Galaxy S23 ça l'aurait disqualifié
directement là c'est pas le cas et il y
a un autre truc qu'il faut savoir et qui
est extrêmement intéressant d'ici
quelques mois je pense normalement c'est
en début d'année Samsung vient présenter
c'est Galaxy S24 et je sais pas si vous
le savez mais Samsung lorsqu'ils
viennent de sortir un nouveau smartphone
je dirais quelques mois après assez
rapidement les tarif baisse directement
donc aujourd'hui vous avez un Galaxy S23
F à 699 € parce qu'il a le nom Galaxy
S23 mais dès lors que sortiront les
Galaxy S24 le Galaxy S23 de base bien va
baisser il tombera en dessous des 799 €
je pense pour faire de la place
davantage au Galaxy S24 parce que ça
sera à ce moment-là l'objectif de
Samsung de venir en ventere davantage
donc ça serait pas surprenant de voir
descendre le tarif du Galaxy S23 sans
pour autant l'éclater mais de fait le
tarif du Galaxy S23 F risquera bouger un
petit peu peut-être de passer aux
alentours des 650 € peut-être allez
savoir on verra ça à ce moment-là et
autre point qui est important et sur
lequel Samsung compte énormément et
développe de plus en plus c'est son
écosystème qui est très complet un peu
comme un Apple hein qui a son écosystème
quoi qu' encore Apple c'est différent
parce qu'ils ont leur OS propriétaire
derrière qui je dirais bah enferme en
tout cas cloisonne un peu plus là comme
on est sur une base d'Android c'est un
peu différent mais derrière vous avez
tout ce qui va bien chez Samsung vous
avez quick Charat pour venir partager
vos fichiers très facilement photo et
compagnie l'auto switch pour venir
switcher lorsque vous êtes sur un
ordinateur que vous êtes sur votre
smartphone pour prendre vos appels
directement avec vos bus d'un côté et de
l'autre tout l'écosystème Galaxy
tablette écouteur montre téléviseur
machine à laver réfrigérateur on en
parle très bientôt les hutes les plaques
de cuisson bref c'est un ensemble qui
est très complet super intéressant avec
Smart sings avec c'est dur à dire avec
Smart sings au milieu et puis il y a un
autre truc qui est très fort et supra
supra supra cool ici c'est la force de
l'os vous êtes ici sur oneui 6 qui était
sorti il y a pas très longtemps et qu'on
retrouve directement ici aujourd'hui sur
le Galaxy S23 fe c'est une superbe
expérience logiciel avec plein de
nouveautés que personnellement j'adore
on en parle bientôt d'ailleurs de toutes
les nouveautés de oneu i6 et surtout
c'estes 4 ans de montée d'os donc là on
est sur une base d'Android 14 on faire
Android 15 16 17 18 et 5 ans de mise à
jour autant vous dire qu'ici c'est un
très gros avantage parce que même si
vous n'achetez pas ce smartphone à sa
sortie fin 2023 que vous l'achetez en
2024 voir 2025 et bien vous aurez encore
4 ans si vous l'achetez en 2025 encore 4
ans de mise à jour de sécurité en fait
ce qui est cool c'est qu'aujourd'hui on
vient acheter des smartphones qu'on va
garder plus longtemps dans le temps et
avec toutes ces mises à jour montedo s
plus sécurité le Galaxy S23 fe s'inscrit
totalement dans cette tendance à la
question faut-il venir acheter le Galaxy
S23 fe pour moi la réponse sera oui si
vous en avez le budget si vous avez les
600 et quelques balles à venir mettre
ici dans ce smartphone vous pouvez y
aller je trouve super intéressant moi ce
qui m'intéresse ici surtout c'est la
polyvalence qu'on va pouvoir venir avoir
avec ce smartphone que ce soit en terme
d'écran que ce soit en terme de
multimédia que ce soit en terme de photo
en terme de vidéo je trouve bon
d'ailleurs dites-moi vous ce que vous
pensez de ce Galaxy S23 F est ce qu'il
vous intéresse oui nonoi com et puis
surtout si vous cherchez un nouveau
smartphone et que vous êtes pas sûr que
vous hésitez et bien tous les mois je
vous fais une vidéo savoir quel
smartphone acheter je vous mets la
playlist là quelque part par ici comme
ça vous avez plus qu'à cliquer dessus
alleer voir quel smartphone acheter le
mois que vous voulez vous serez bien
renseigné et ça c'est vachement bien